thank you for coming well this is a lot
of people this is more interest than I
get it my own company that's out for the
record alright let me just introduce
what I do first
so where's OPA it's a world's first
peer-to-peer learning platform where
investors can lend directly to borrowers
so the way we do that is investors come
to us with their money and we split that
into a large number of assets which we
call Michael loans and then those micro
loans used to I used to fund loans for
borrowers on the other side of the
platform here are a few numbers to show
that it's a business it works we've been
around for more than a decade lent out
more than 3 billion pounds but today
I'll be focusing on that portfolio
optimization part where we need to form
essentially bags of assets for our
investors such that they satisfy
constraints meaning that portfolios get
a certain amount of return for a given
amount of risk and among many other
things I will show how to frame that
problem is an integer programming
problem
so yesterday general spoke about how
it's actually one of the more difficult
of transition problems and I'll discuss
how we solve it in our platform and use
the PI data stack to make it very very
fast conceptually it has applications
that are much broader than just
portfolio optimization you can apply
these insights to capital budgeting
cutting stock scheduling and many other
problems so what unites them is that
these optimization problems are
combinatorial and so are np-hard
which in plain English means that they
are intractable they don't scale well
and if you just try to brute force them
you'll never get a solution this is how
you would formulate them mathematically
don't be intimidated by the math so all
it says is that we need to assemble the
most valuable portfolios for our
investors such that they are affordable
I the money that they gave us need to be
spent
they need to be of a certain risk
profile that satisfies their preferences
and they need to yield a certain amount
of return among other things
so the key constraint that makes this
problem difficult is the last one
actually this is an integer programming
problem you cannot use gradient descent
and in the worst case scenario you'll
just end up enumerate in all possible
cases which in this case me is
complexity of 2 to the power M times n
where m is the number of investors and n
the number of micro loans formally this
is what is called multiple multi
dimensional map stack problem yesterday
Gianluca in one of the pileated sessions
showed that even with a million assets
he couldn't solve it on his laptop
exactly so you know if that doesn't
convince you that this is not a trivial
problem there is a textbook just on
variations of this single problem it's
300 pages and it's full of dense proofs
so you know that's when you know your
manager through an interesting problem
luckily in the ecosystem we have
third-party servers written by companies
like Google and C++ with Python bindings
usually very fast very reliable or you
can go about it using genetic algorithms
that would smartly explore the solution
space the problem with them is that
especially the third party solvers that
we tried is that they are very slow even
though they do something smarter than
just brute force what is called
branch-and-bound
still because in the worst case you're
still in the marais ting every possible
case it can take days this is how you
would set it up so very briefly you
sense you need to initialize a bunch of
integer variables you define the
constraints so the and the constraint
number one is what I call the
affordability constraint right so you
just need to deal with in your budget
and the second one is a
the return constraint which is you need
to get a certain amount of return and
finally the last one is the objective
which which we simply tell all our tools
this is a Google optimization so
operations research tools to maximize
unfortunately at our scale it won't work
because it needs to solve essentially
for a matrix of M by n M investors and
micro loans and that's billions of
variables it can take days to do that
and in addition when you design
something more custom that is less
abstracted from you you can incorporate
business priorities you know in an
easier way and that's the path we chose
to design our own algorithm of course
because the problem is np-hard we
couldn't do that exactly so you need to
you need to simplify these kind of
things the the key simplification is
that we're not looking actually for the
very very best solution we just need to
find a feasibly good one that gets a
synonym or return set amount of risk
while exhausting a person's budget the
key insight from a technical point of
view is that the knapsack problem has a
greedy choice property meaning that you
can advance one set up a time you simply
have to iterate through assets and for
every one select the most appropriate
buyer using some heuristics and those
heuristics I usually create it using
nuance business knowledge because it's a
single loop over assets and for every
asset you need to evaluate suitability
of every investor in the worst case
scenario complexity is only to the order
of M times n which is orders and orders
of magnitude faster than 2 to the power
n this is the solution at a bird's eye
view
we process investors that come to our
platform in batches
they go into the common pool of these
kind of you know microloans assets and
then the portfolio optimization
algorithm or the matching algorithm
forms new portfolios brief note on how
to design this kind of greedy algorithms
it's a very general problem-solving
technique where you simply make the best
choice at the current step without
looking ahead you are affected by what
happened before but you're not looking
ahead and in machine learning an example
of an algorithm does exactly that is
actually there
you know id3 algorithm to learn decision
trees at every node you are splitting by
them the best variable without thinking
of how it might affect you down the path
this can be a lot a lot faster than
enumerate in all possible cases as might
happen and then I'm a programming or
branch-and-bound a key component that
you would need to create all right
yourself are the feasibility function so
filter for the appropriate candidate set
the investors that can they're actually
eligible for this asset a selection
function based on heuristics for every
assets you need to calculate some
suitability and then assign to that
investor and a solution functions the
checks actually that all the constraints
are satisfied because some of you may
know so the greedy algorithm does not
guarantee that the solution will be well
not only does not guarantee that will be
optimal it does not guarantee that it
will satisfy the constraints so that's
why you need to be worried about that
this is an illustration of how that
algorithm works so you have a bunch of
assets in that you trade one by one so
yeah you considering let's say this
green ball and you're thinking okay
which invested or do I give it to the
scoring function then calculate some
school the logic at a high level is
basically we know where we need to get
you we know where you are and we and we
hypothesize so if I were to give you
assets how close how much more how much
closer would you be to your target
portfolio so in this case the second
investor is the one for whom this asset
would benefit the most it would bring
him or her closer closest to to their
target but fully and so that's it would
therefore be assigned to them as you can
tell this is very custom you won't find
libraries to just import and do this for
you so we wrote this completely from
scratch our back end is a very pythonic
and in general we love Python so we
didn't want to have components written
in C or even syphon so we wanted to
leverage the best of the Pilatus that
can offer and followed roughly the this
kind of workflow where reporters have
been pandas so first you always need to
optimize for research speed when you
don't know what the heuristic should be
don't know what the algorithm looks like
and pandas usually it's very good for
that it's very convenient for database
connections data manipulations group
bias can be very painful and numpy so
upon this is the way to go
secondly when then speed becomes crucial
the easiest thing to do is to perform
computation on numpy erase paralyze
where possible and the last mile when
you know the algorithm is performance
critical you can compile it using number
and I'll discuss those steps in detail
so you know the algorithm is ready now
you know that's okay I need to make it
fast because when you move people's
money around the transaction failure is
very costly and we work in a very
regulated industry so this kind of
components need to be robust
but before refactoring codes are always
always profile even with intuition it's
sometimes you can be surprised actually
it's one setting things are faster than
others so in in Python you either have
the choice of largely C Python which
will profile every function in the
module or what I prefer personally the
line profiler extension to ipython where
you simply need to load it and you can
profile every function call in the down
the stack and then every single line in
the function will be profiled for you so
in this case I'm profiling the function
score asset which is called insight
allocates assets and saving that from
saving the results in the file
ESCO mcl dot txt and this is roughly can
how that how the output might look like
it would go line by line and show you
how many times that function was called
how many seconds were spent there per
hit and percentage of time overall so
you will know where to focus your
efforts essentially and which parts to
leave alone which parts to refactor
here's another example of a profiling
report so you know you start writing
pandas you have a huge data frame of
portfolios with all sorts of metrics and
you need to index them to during
iteration that is very very slow so as
you can see going from pandas to numpy
purely for indexing can deliver 3 230 X
speed-up that is just massive for
something that is relatively small
change to the code base let's delve a
bit into why that is the case so data
frame is simply a wrapper around a numpy
array on top of that array it will
provide you label axis so indexes for
rows
and column names for the other dimension
Enix is a big essentially a big mapping
they are immutable so knowing things
like that can help you understand why
certain operations should be avoided and
why they are slow so for example in a
numerical algorithm that is iterative
you will be adding stuff to a pending
stuff too to enter an array if you do
that with a data frame they'll be very
slow because the index is immutable and
every time your pend you're creating it
from a new and copying everything again
each data frame column is upon the
series with an underlying numpy array it
allows pandas to store a race of
collagenous types I different columns
can be able different types but if
within the same column we have different
types for example strings and integers
it will revert back to Python object
container type which will prevent any
type optimization type specific
optimization due to an amp I here is a
slide from Geoffrey triteness talk I
also think Geoffrey back so both of them
contribute to pandas they've touched on
this before of how for historical
reasons pandas stores data frames in
memory so it's not just you know one big
data frame actually it stores axes
separately so column names indexes and
then blocks of data according to their
type so you know the orange block is
just object then you have integers
billions floats and so on and when you
append you will be creating all of this
from scratch again copying and then
adding that new row rather than
modifying in place for that memory slot
they'll be very slow the key takeaway is
do not rely on planets when speed is
crucial avoids appending to the data
frame especially when your loop is over
millions of items avoids applying
a function with using the apply method
to rose because it will
behind-the-scenes it's just a for loop
that is indexing every single row so and
as you saw indexing in pandas is super
super slow when you do need a data frame
for example for the consumer of the
algorithm at the end or for some data
manipulations inside the algorithm or
for some database connection and so on
created once at the very end outside the
mathematical logic of the algorithm if
you must iterate the best way to do that
is through either it's a tuples method
it's a generator that will give you
every row as a named tuple and knowing
how pandas actually works
from what we just seen you can reproduce
it functionality in an pi so columns
might be coming in different order right
so it's not always the case that price
will be first then it will be an
investor's capital so that's why
indexing by a string is so convenient
you don't need to worry about okay which
one is the first which one is the second
enum PI you won't have that luxury but
you can recreate the functionality by
creating extra data structures that
mimic what pandas X is give T so here
you have you know a numpy array with a
bunch of data obviously you don't have
column names but you can create a
dictionary or even better and named
tuple where the string is mapped to a
number so the price is mapped to 0 for
example and when you index a numpy array
with the second dimension to that I the
dictionaries item you will get exactly
the column 0 I hope that makes sense
that way you get rid of pun as well
still having the functionality of the
indexes and column names and as I show
you earlier also now that's what will
allow you to work
scene with to move seamlessly between
from pandas to a number and just-in-time
compilation
next is parallelization so for example
when you know algorithm when we score
investors for the assets that is done
independently one investor suitability
for that asset is independent of another
that means is parallelizable but in
Python if you simply create multiple
threads that won't work that's not true
parallelization because of a global
interpreter lock meaning that in your
interpreter only one thread will be
executing at a time which will prevent
any optimizations in fact it will slow
it down due to overhead the way multi
processing in Python actually works is
several interpreters need to be
initialized each having its own global
interpreter lock each working on its own
CPU but for them to communicate their
needs to be serialization of your data
so you can think of it as like you need
to pickle all the data
pass it around between different
interpreters and of course that will
incur overheads so for example if you
you have 4 CPUs that's one of the
reasons why you won't observe 4x speed
up exactly thankfully that is abstracted
away by Joe blip which allows you to
mount a multi-process in essentially one
line you just need to define the
parallel class you specify the number of
CPUs you want to use so here I'm using
all the CPUs that I've available and we
have 16 I believe on the machine that it
runs on the lathe is simply the way to
not run the algorithm straight away it
serialized it and then
executed on separate interpreters and as
I said so the paralyzation in the
algorithm that I outlined happens in
batches of investors or in fact the
scoring function also has a bunch of
parameters and you can also paralyze
that and that is what is called
embarrassingly parallel meaning that
it's very straightforward to paralyze it
because everything is independent of
another process all right
so usually that should be enough numpy
plus parallelization but if you want to
work the last mile if you want to
squeeze that extra bits out of Python
you can use number which is a very
recent library we prefer to Thyssen
because it keeps the codebase pythonic
it is very easy to implement it comes
with quite extensive functionality for
speeding up scientific computation
including parallelization and in fact as
I will show it releases a Gil as well
and surprisingly for the little amount
of effort as we will see that it
requires it can actually be faster than
a siphon and it can match C++ codes from
what the open source community has
demonstrated here's how it works behind
the scenes there's a lot of heavy
loading so is you know the C Python
compiles your Python function into byte
code then number analyzer that creates
an intermediate representation that is a
template then it can then it does type
inference for you rewrite set
intermediate representation and then
passes on to LVM which is a language
agnostic compiler that
deform first optimizations and rewrite
that code into machine code for
appropriate platform either CPU or you
know you can even do GPU code for you
let's see how it works here's a simple
function to calculate return of the
portfolio so we defined simply as a
weighted average of assets in that
portfolio in it's very easy to vectorize
in but as you can see in number it will
be who four times faster if you provide
it with the correct specs that so let's
say so let's walk through the
functionality and how some performance
tips for a number first I have the
decorator here chit which is the
just-in-time
meaning that you won't be creating any
compiled code ahead of time it will just
pick it up when you actually call the
function at execution time and only then
do all the inference all the
optimization and compilation the first
argument is type signature you don't
have to do it usually number can infer
the right types for you but for
performance critical algorithm I prefer
to write them down because sometimes
type inference might not work exactly
the way you expect it to integers being
converted to floats and so on second
parameter is in know Python mode so when
number cannot infer the types that it
can work with or when the type in the
type check fails against the type
signature that you provide it will fail
to object mode which is you can think of
it as just the Python mode any
optimization gains will be essentially
eliminated and the code will be might
essentially be slower due to overhead
second one is apart
so you can tell number to create
multiple threats and release the global
interpreter lock so this will be even
faster than multi processing in Python
because you are not civilizing data
you're not you don't need to communicate
between several worker processes it's
true multi-threading but mind the
overhead it's still you're still setting
up threats so for arrays of smaller than
100 I have found that it's not worth it
and actually slows down the algorithm
but let's say if you have a race of
thousand or more you will see
significant speed ups the last parameter
is a fast math is what is telling the
LLVM compiler to auto vectorize meaning
that the cpu will execute several
operations at once vectorization but you
need to be mindful of the fact that
floating-point arithmetic is not
associative so it will start moving
around different numbers and so you
might get different results if you care
about floating-point accuracy so if
sixteenth digit after the decimal is
what is what you care about then don't
set it to true and then you know it's a
compiler so there will be cost of
compilation incurred when you first call
it you can cache the results in memory
or on disk so that only the first time
is flawed but all the subsequent times
will be really fast but don't get closes
so it's probably an interesting trick
interview question if you get a closure
does it compile every time you call a
function or just once it will compile
every time you call the function because
the closure inside the function is
defined every time you run the function
so now that will be really slow
some more tips from our experienced the
type inference is a set and always work
as you expect or number can fail to
infer them correctly so to be safe fast
type signatures you know exactly what
kind of behavior you'll get on the other
end you can pass multiple signatures
going from most specific to list
specific so 64 bit loads all the way to
a bit induce and you know it does
compile code into something low level so
the exceptions that you may get can be
very obscure so some debugging tips you
can access the intermediate
representation by calling the inspect
types methods on the compiled function
and we'll essentially show you line by
line how number interpretive that I
won't be showing you the output of that
because it's pretty well it's not pretty
but what you need to look out for is the
type so it will you know here from the
previous slide I had like float64 so you
need to look out that every arguments
that Quentin actually was it actually
managed to infer the coerced into
float64 if it couldn't what you will see
is a pie object object which means it
will revert to Python modes of course if
you said no Python argument to true it
will warn you it will just throw you an
exception so it won't work
and finally the you know annotate HTML
is what will allow you to produce the
reports that will again show the
intimate representation with how number
translated your code even though the
just-in-time compiler is sort of its
core functionality it comes with a lot
of bells and whistles it can do
universal functions for you so one of
the workshop yesterday touched on that
numpy you fonts that will do all the
broadcasting for you type coercion and
so on you can even do generalized
Universal functions so you can define
your own broadcasting role
yeah so this is a way to speed up
convolution for example it you can write
CUDA compile code and you can also what
they're still working is like ahead of
time compilation so they can compile
ahead of time and then communicate with
remote service for example so here's our
algorithm it's a bird's-eye-view bit of
stop firing as I said three key
components of the greedy algorithm the
filtering function the scoring function
and then the solution function the
scoring function is the crux of it and
it's what takes the most time so that's
what we compile using number the loop
that the greedy algorithm relies on is
inherently serial so what goes next
depends on what happened before so you
cannot paralyze that so it's in a health
issue the procedure that's why a number
shines because loops in Python are very
slow we're sure many of you know that
and that's what number will make very
fast so our solution process is 1
million assets in 20 seconds as opposed
to days it has so far processed tens of
millions of pounds for thousands of
investors and never violated at our key
constraints I do hope it made them as
happy as those faces and finally some
takeaways simplify whenever possible and
especially when this problem is np-hard
optimize very such speeds first that's
why I think we use Python it's so good
for that profile for a factoring and
then delve under how things work under
the hood to speed it up and yeah we've
been very happy with using number
it keeps the code based pythonic easy to
read easy to implement and people are
discussing of the replacing size and in
some of the key pi data library searches
you know sci-fi and pandas for size and
- number so it has all our potential
and finally if you want to learn more
you can go to our blog and of course is
a little bit of sanctities in Ireland so
it's a lot of team work and I would like
to give acknowledgements to my
colleagues Keisha and Francisco and
Jahan I hope you enjoy the top thinking
[Applause]
[Music]